[Music]
know anybody in Washington but now I
know everybody in Washington I know the
good ones I know the bad ones I know the
wonderful people and I know the scum and
America now is winning again like they
haven't won before I am for America
first and the American worker we want to
be a puppet for no one any longer we're
not going to be a puppet any longer all
right that was the president earlier
tonight in Florida President Trump is
staying focused on implementing his
agenda keeping his promises while the
Russia witch-hunt continues despite zero
evidence after four hundred and whatever
many days of Russia collusion Russia
collusion today former New York City
police commissioner Bernie Kerik you
wrote an op-ed very important quote
Muller's weaponized justice system
should scare all Americans Bernie Kerik
hero of 9/11 joins us in studio along
with the author she is now the number
one best-selling author the New York
Times
now that is the hugest accomplishment
for a person that I love admire and she
fills on on this show and she's got our
own show Liars leakers liberals the case
against the indy trump conspiracy host
of justice judging in pure here's what I
here's a problem I have so grace book
came out much after yours your book has
been number one on the New York Times
list okay he's number one on Amazon so I
got the to number one people here you
love you we all come on to be on your
show all right I love it when you here's
what I'm worried about
here's I want to bring people inside the
justice system this is a different
discussion Sammy the bull Gravano didn't
they know he killed 19 people they did
right yeah okay
they gave him a deal they said if you
testify that was against John Gotti
senior at the time okay
the Teflon dog you testify we're gonna
put you in jail for killing 19 people
some say 20 he then gets the government
to give him a house in Arizona in the
witness protection program in other
words they put the screws to him if you
sing
compose I don't know what he did I don't
remember the case we're gonna give you a
sweetheart deal now you got all these
people getting sweetheart deals in the
matter for K so here's my question as a
judge and as an attorney how often did
they offer deals like this and aren't
there many people that'll say well what
do you want me to say to keep me out of
jail look there's no question and it
speaks to the article that Bernie wrote
today and that is that US Attorney's
very often have a political agenda and
that political agenda will determine
whether or not they want to forgive
someone who was murdered 19 people that
they can prove beyond a reasonable doubt
so that they can go after someone else
they're going after Muller and and
Bernie can talk about this because they
want to squeeze him they're going after
Michael Kawhi would you let somebody who
killed 19 people make a deal isn't he
gonna say whatever you want to say well
you know what when I was a DA I would
make deals with drug dealers to get
after the guy who was above that drug
dealer you do it all the time in law
enforcement okay but what credibility
did they have Bernie and this goes to
the heart of your article today listen
the the credibility is slimming and
here's here's the problem every one of
the people I mentioned in the article
Cohen Flynn and man afford they are
specifically investigative targets just
because they knew Trump just because
they were associated from all three and
Cohen who I'm pretty disappointed with
at this stage but Cohen ironically was
his attorney and they targeted him
intentionally for this reason to create
a conflict make him a witness and
guarantee that he can no longer talk to
Trump that's the purpose behind
targeting the attorney and now you know
you talk about you talk about what they
did with Sammy the bull they charged
Michael Flynn with one false statement
by the way
and Comey said they didn't think he was
lying right and he's had to sell his
home and they said well we're gonna go
after your kid I'm assuming that
happened and I've guarantee you would
happen and he said so what father's not
going to dive on the sword to kill
themselves
again did he do that problem question
they do it all the time that's what they
do to get people to plead we're going
after your sound stupid upon your mother
your daughter we want this guy in in
order to get him everyone he's ever
touches why would a jury ever believes
somebody who cut a deal to save their
ass because the prosecutor will pick a
jury and he will tell them look this is
the only way we can prove a crime we
don't even like doing what we do and
then the jury says we'll wait a minute
and what they're doing in the Manafort
case they're bringing in all kinds of
evidence to show he thinks he's above
the law
he bought Persian rugs and he bought an
ostrich Jack how great was the judge
today if you excuse me if you're wealthy
it's not a crime right he's great he's
great judge I give this judge a lot of
credit Emmitt Sullivan the judge in the
Flynn case the new judge these guys know
Sullivan said I'll decide what's
exculpatory give me all of it no that's
exactly right in that's fortunate for
these men and because normally that's
not the case
normally the prosecutors federal
prosecutors sort of run rogue over these
these these cases and when they do so
the judges sit back and let them do what
they want if I'm on a jury and I'm
listening to the defense ask now did you
cut a deal with those guys over there
just so did they threaten to put you in
jail did they say you're not going to go
to jail if you do this I'm dismissing
that person because I don't believe you
if you cut a deal to get out of jail
you're gonna be honest you are basically
bribed and paid yes but if you have
people sitting on a jury and the
prosecutor has already has them yes or
no sir no yes yes I'm bribing the
witnesses worse than that sometimes
they're bribing the witnesses to get
them to testify but a lot of times hos
they bait and it's what Alan Dershowitz
said earlier they extort testimony
that's false out of these acts what
judge Ellis meant when he said he said
compose would you like me to say to keep
me out of jail
it's
same with Michael Cohen I said on my
show this weekend that guy he'll confess
to sinking the Titanic because he wants
to get out of jail and when the jury
looks at them they're gonna say well the
prosecutor makes a good case they had to
do this to get the evidence otherwise
they can't get the bad guy sorry I don't
believe bribery is the only way to get
you know the conviction rate is in
federal prosecutors 97 98 percent eight
percent I guess pretty sports it's 65 to
75 percent around the country the feds
got you by this why what did you have to
say that I'm gonna make news you're
gonna be on the headline a media why did
you say that because I want them to know
my point is that the feds when they
switch you they squeeze you tight all
right
good to see you both we got a roll by
the way judge P Rose book right now in
the New York Times number saber liars
legal Oh in stores everywhere right
number one on Amazon you've been out for
how many weeks proud of